okay so Jeremy mckimie asked at the
retreat we were at I asked you to define
hierarchy and loved your answer perhaps
you could discuss it here how do you
define hierarchy
what is its ecclesiastical
ecclesiastical and cosmological
significance how does it flesh out in
healthy and unhealthy ways
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
hierarchy hierarchy is the way that the
world lays itself out in there are
different hierarchies obviously but
hierarchy is the result of caring it's
the result of value it's the result of
of mind you know it's it's inevitable
that because we are conscious
intelligent beings that the world will
lay itself out in terms of hierarchy um
and so so there are different types
there are different hierarchies or their
their hierarchies of value let's say
moral hierarchies their hierarchies like
Jordan Peterson talks about hierarchies
of competence they're their hierarchies
of ontological hierarchies you know and
so let's say the spiritual hierarchy
would be an ontological hierarchy that
is that is you have you have
principalities and then you have God and
then you have creation human beings so
that would be like that would be like
the the highest form of hierarchy the
hierarchy in when it's done right what
it does is that it both separates and
unifies it both both it both shows you
what's higher like shows you the
distance between you and the highest
thing but it also gives you a path
towards that highest thing it gives you
a path towards towards what's above you
okay that's the way that hierarchy is is
supposed to work it's supposed to do
both at the same time now the MA like
let's say the kind of postmodern vision
of hierarchy is that it only separates
right so hierarchies are evil because
they create you know levels and then
they separate people from they separate
values from one another and so it's like
if if there's something in hierarchy
then there's someone above you and he
has more power than you and you have
less it doesn't mean that that can
happen that way definitely it can that
there can be hierarchies which are based
solely on on on power and let's just say
strength but I would say that like
functional hierarchy is really really is
something in which you recognize where
you are in the hierarchy okay so I'll
give you an example you're working for a
company and then you have a boss
now if the hierarchy is normal and and
you are participating in that hierarchy
right you could you could see yourself
let's say you're let's say you're I
don't know you're a busboy in a
restaurant right in a normal hierarchy
you should be able to see that the boss
is making is letting you participate in
this hierarchy like it's your way of
participating in the hierarchy but you
couldn't do what the boss does at least
not yet but you you need to you would
need to work yourself up the hierarchy
in order to come to a point where you
could do what the boss wants
right a dysfunctional vision of it would
be oh that jerk that you know the boss
is jerk and and you know they are the
only reason why I'm here as a busboy is
because you know he has more power or
whatever but in a normal hierarchy it
would be okay this is where I am and
this is actually where I should be
because I don't know how to run a
restaurant I have no idea I can do this
I can do the dishes you know I can fetch
stuff and then once I do that then maybe
I can go up the hierarchy and then when
I can do that I can go up the hierarchy
and and and I can ascend the hierarchy
like that's a normal hierarchy it's the
same with let's say in hierarchy of
sites you know I stand here and I look
let's say at-at-at Saints and I see the
distance between myself and that saint I
can see that st. Seraphim of Sarov or
Saint Gregory of Nyssa I read their
lives I see what they wrote and I think
wow who okay
I see the distance between myself and
them but at the same time I also they're
also let's say part of the ladder right
I can see them as part of the ladder
towards what's high beyond them which is
Christ right so Christ is that is at the
top of the hierarchy and I can see
Christ in them as being what I need
to acquire in order to to ascend the the
hierarchy one of the problems with the
absence of hierarchies and we see this
in some in certain churches is that
because because there aren't steps that
show you what
what's higher than you let's say you
know then it's like it's just like it's
a in terms of spirit routes like it's me
and God right it's me and God and so
what happens is that maybe sometimes
like me and God but then somebody's like
me and God right and you see God pretty
low you you bring God down to your level
because you don't have that ladder which
shows you just how lofty the infinite is
right just how lofty God is supposed to
be but if you have a hierarchy of saints
and of angels that are loftier and
loftier and loftier and are and are more
free and are more pure and and have more
virtue than I can see oh okay yeah I'm
far like you know I can still be in a
relationship with God but I I also have
to bow down and know that God isn't my
buddy right God isn't my you know I saw
a horrible one of the one of the most
frustrating things I saw in Montreal
recently and every I think I might have
told you guys is before maybe not every
year in Montreal the Catholic Church
they organized the tithe and so they
they have these these posters or they
advertise for tithing and and this year
I swear I swear this is true this year
the image was a was a was a it was like
it was like just dark and and it had a
like a wavy pattern on it like that and
a ton on top it said it said what was it
like hello Jesus dot dot dot and then at
the bottom it says your personal
assistant is always available I swear I
swear I
if I could have
an accident in in on the street when I
saw that I was like oh my goodness yeah
it's like you that when you see that
you're like okay maybe I should be an
atheist seriously when I see something
like that it's like I have sympathy for
for sam harris at those small moments I
have sympathy for sam harris all right